Hello there, and welcome to
this unusual AI Coffee Break.
Ms. Coffee Bean forced me
to relax a bit and have more
fun than we usually do when discussing
papers in our totally serious fashion.
Wheeee!
Yes, serious! Totally serious,
we have to be serious, it’s science!
This video starts with a throwback to
this comment of a Reddit user about one
of my first videos with Ms. Coffee Bean.
So someone on Reddit said that
I should ditch the TTS...!
Which means that they think I have used a TTS
for that video... TTS is "text to speech".
Let's hear a snippet from
that video, is it that bad?
"Hello there! In the last video, we
outlined the history of the Transformer".
Oh, I think that was the wrong audio file,
because it really sounded like TTS.
Ok, now with the correct audio file.
"I hope that now that you know about the
transformer's success and proliferation..."
Wow, I could have spoken that so much better...
But what did I know back
then? We were still so young,
and you were just a little Ms. Coffee Bean!
Today you’re like 2 pixels bigger, right?
But let’s stick to that TTS a little bit,
because there is a reason why we used
exactly the text-to-speech you heard:
It is the default TTS packed with
NVIDIA Jarvis releasing today. Yay!
So let’s hear again its output because
it is more to it than you first hear:
"And if you are not very much excited yet, this
is the best part of the Transformers. [Okay.]
They train very easily with self-supervision
[woo, cool!], meaning that they do not
necessarily need annotated training data [that's
awesome!] to be able to capture human language."
There could be some improvement here, right?
But there are also very good parts!
We can blame the good and the bad
parts onto different parts that come into the TTS.
And here is where NVIDIA Jarvis comes in:
While I was using here the default models that are
already trained on lots and lots of training data,
the whole Jarvis AI is modular such that you
can exchange the parts you are not content with,
with other better ones that you
or someone else has trained.
And not only with better modules, but with more
specific ones, until you are content with it
and the whole system is ready to deploy.
Like I would like to train the TTS to
synthesize my voice and my thick eastern
European accent to speak these videos.
In accent: "And you haven't even
heard my eastern European accent yet!"
My ultimate goal is to make
Ms. Coffee Bean fully sentient!
But because I do not want to train those
better or specific modules from scratch,
NVIDIA has got me covered, since you can
take the existing models and fine-tune them
in the Transfer Learning Toolkit on
your own data to make it better fit
your style or, you know, your
customers if you have any.
Then you can deploy it with Jarvis which
optimizes the models and makes them fast
for exactly the GPU you are using such that
your deployed models can work real-time.
And it's really easy to set up! It only took
Letitia like a whole day to get it to run,
while I sat in the coffee roaster the whole time!
Nah, kidding, Letitia just needed the whole
day to figure out that 8GB of VRAM are
not enough for some of the bigger Natural
Language Understanding Modules of Jarvis.
And while NVIDIA kindly
offered to provide a bigger GPU
which she did not accept,
they also let her know how to get it
to run on her measly 3070 RTX. Phew!
And afterwards it took only minutes to set up the
Text-to-Speech functionality
of Jarvis for this video.
So for the Jarvis default Text-To-Speech,
one does not need more than 8 GB
of VRAM and it's fact checked!
And the TTS is just a tiny part of NVIDIA
Jarvis: it comes also with Speech to text
and Natural Language Understanding
modules that you can combine how you
want. Just think about the possibilities of
creating your own applications with that.
It can help you transcribe your chat
with another person or tag Named Entities
and answer your questions.
But why are are so hyped about it?
Because it is multimodal!
It comes already with speech
and language and Nvidia promises vision
too. And you know how much Ms. Coffee
Bean likes multimodality especially between
vision and language. Check out her videos
about that, she has a playlist.
So what are you still doing here?
Go, and try out NVIDIA Jarvis and
build your cool applications with it!
Do not forget to like and subscribe!
Ok bye!